we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's
something great a self-described boomer
called into the show this woman is
delightful she has the requisite david
pakman show playing in the background
while she leaves the voicemail this is
just a classic now for david pakman show
callers we had a call last week from
someone who said why aren't the boomers
out protesting and i pointed out you
know it always tends to be younger
populations that disproportionately
protest and we have a pandemic that
disproportionately affects older folks
so it seems totally expected and
reasonable that we're not seeing as many
baby boomers out protesting check out
this voicemail from my new favorite
david pakman show caller hi I'm a boomer
I'm 68 years old and you know what there
are a lot of rumors out there protesting
but those of us who have all respiratory
disease and who are extremely vulnerable
to the corona virus really hesitate
about putting ourselves into big groups
of people of course so anyway that's my
two cents makes absolute perfect sense
delightful self-described boomer with
the David Pakman show playing in the
background you were completely right and
this was exactly what I said I and it
just makes sense and listen after what
happened to Martin Gugino
75 year old protester who got knocked
down by police hit the back of his head
bled from his ear and spent nearly a
week in the hospital if you're going to
assume that as an older person the
police won't manhandle you that is not
being borne out we have at least a half
a dozen incidents including the elderly
man walking with a cane I forget where
maybe it was Atlanta although if it was
and I apologize who was knocked down by
police there's a bunch of these
incidents so I I don't believe for a
second that the so-called boomers
necessarily don't support what's going
on
but they seem to understand the risks
associated with gathering in large
crowds we're seeing what's happening in
Texas Florida as they've reopened
spiking cases it's ugly so I totally
understand and respect what they're
doing here's something fun if things are
so negative lately come on and do
something fun
Tuesday night this is Tuesday June 16
8:00 p.m. Eastern Time 8:00 p.m. Eastern
5 Pacific David Pakman show chess
tournament number two I don't care if
you have never played chess I mean you
want to know how the pieces move but the
point is open to all skill levels join
the tournament we will be streaming it
live at 8:00 p.m. Eastern but you don't
have to just watch me play in the
tournament you can play in it you can
register on Leach s org so that you're
ready to go that's a lie
chess dot-org it's gonna be great we had
500 people roughly play last time I'm
hoping that we do far better than that
this time and of course remember that we
have a daily free podcast that you can
sign up for on Spotify Apple iTunes
Google Play etc etc etc the daily audio
podcast another great way to receive the
show on today's bonus show we will be
covering dr. Anthony foul G's latest
coronavirus comments we will talk about
US soccer lifting the ban on kneeling
during the national anthem and amazon
has banned police use of its face
recognition technology for a year is
this PRBS are significant all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
become a member at join pakman.com and
we'll see you on the bonus show or
tomorrow